I'm talking this morning with Anthony
Weiner of the European Commission at the
opening day of the ftth conference in
London until you gave a talk this
morning tell us some of the main
highlights of what you had to say
morning Brian well the main news I
brought was unfortunately not good news
it was that the heads of government of
the EU have decided for a major cut in
the proposal for the connecting Europe
facility which would have been a support
for public-private partnerships to fund
high-speed broadband throughout Europe
now the why is there so disappointing
give us a bit more insight into it well
Brian first of all it's a disappointing
signal about the recognition by
government leaders of the importance of
high-speed networks to the overall
European economy as a factor for growth
it's also disappointing because what we
were putting forward was innovative
financial instruments which are a great
way of leveraging private finance into
funding these infrastructure needs it on
a long-term basis it's much more
efficient than national grants or
subsidies and it would have been as I
said a great form of public-private
partnership for these networks now that
won't be possible with earmark European
funding but we are still working to
promote these sort of instruments
through structural funds and other
European financial measures in what's
the problem do you think governments
just don't quite get it don't they
realize the importance of this kind of
infrastructure well I refer to
innovative financial instruments and
things that are you are often difficult
to sell in a heartful budgetary context
governments are more used to funding
traditional infrastructures like
transport they also have stronger
lobbies so we certainly have to take
away from this that we need to keep
making the political case that ICT
counts for fifty percent of productivity
gains already in the European economy
and those gains will only be achieved
with fit-for-purpose networks that can
last into the future meeting future
needs
and do you think we can do it can we get
there well we have not conceded defeat
there are a lot of other things on the
table that can help here Nelly coos is
working on regulatory reforms that will
make sure the price signals are right to
support expensive long-term new
investments she is working on a
legislative proposal to remove a number
of unnecessary administrative obstacles
in the member states to to cheaper roll
out cheaper civil wax faster para
matting more infrastructure sharing with
other utilities and that won't be easy
we need political support for that but
we need to persuade the very top level
of political leadership but this is
vital for our economies yes because i
think you know you were saying that you
know 15 years ago europe sort of led the
world in new technology and we've kind
of lost that position yes I think a lot
of Europeans don't yet realize that we
invented effectively mobile telephony
and led the world in that we liberalize
markets in a way that put us in a
leadership position 10 to 15 years ago
and we have lost that other countries
other continents are forging ahead with
much more high-speed fixed and wireless
networks which are all part of a single
ecosystem and we need our leaders to
realize that we are slowly but surely
slipping behind and we need to regain
the advantage okay well let's hope we
could get there and thanks for sharing
those views with us this morning Thank
You Ryan
you